no aguantara be es una diseñadora siria
de 29 años en 2019 le descubrieron un
cáncer de seno estaba un tratamiento de
ese entonces perdió todo su cabello no
soportaba la idea hasta que decidió
aceptar su nueva identidad en mano
muggle en chile cuando me miro en el
espejo veo a alguien fuerte
pero es cierto que tampoco me veo
extraño mi antiguo yo su halle el anal
el cahuín pero hay esperanza para rawan
y millones de mujeres a través del mundo
que sufren de cáncer de seno
una vacuna propuesta por un grupo de
científicos del instituto de
investigación lerner de la clínica
cleveland en eeuu está en desarrollo
tras 20 años de investigación la vacuna
será ensayada en mujeres que ya han sido
diagnosticadas con cáncer de mama triple
negativo uno de los más agresivos y
tratadas con diferentes tipos de
terapias en la primera fase las
voluntarias recibirán tres dosis de la
vacuna experimental una cada dos semanas
mientras se determina si hay una
respuesta inmunitaria el oncólogo tomás
bot principal investigador del proyecto
dijo a largo plazo nuestra meta es
determinar si esta vacuna es capaz de
combatir el cáncer de seno especialmente
en sus variantes más agresivas antes de
que ocurra de tener éxito podría
convertirse en una terapia preventiva
eficaz incluso para personas sanas según
cifras de la organización mundial de la
salud en 2020 2,3 millones de mujeres en
el mundo fueron diagnosticadas con
cáncer de mama de las cuales
685.000 fallecieron por esa enfermedad